the idea is to think about yeah it's
actually how can a how can an ad-hoc
group of amateurs at an event kind of
meaningfully capture stuff in order to
tell a story about it and this was
inspired by the fact that if you go wood
geek or if you go to any event instead
of kind of lighters in the air you just
see phones up kind of recording
everything everywhere nowadays and so
yeah so the general idea is can we use
that can those people all contribute
towards telling a story of an event on
mass so we start with the gig and
actually that's not such an interesting
example because yeah there's there's
only a certain number of perspectives
you can have any gig so we started
thinking about well what are some other
events that might be more interesting to
film and we thought about kind of
sporting events like running races and
marathons and cycling events that kind
of stuff anything that's that's
geographically distributed around a
course so something that it's going to
be really hard to kind of capture in a
lot of detail so if you think about
something like the London Marathon
you've got a kind of 26 miles of course
and the BBC for example put an awful lot
of effort into kind of deploying kanna
camera equipment in order to cover it so
I think I read that they have 51 haider
high-definition cameras at various
points around the course to produce this
kind of interesting coverage now
interesting as something like the
Notting and Robin Hood marathon is it's
not interesting or big enough for the
BBC to turn up with all that equipment
but lots and lots of people turn out so
you have about 10,000 people turning up
year-on-year so you've got a lot of
people kind of lining the route and
potentially providing the opportunity to
be kind of amateur camera operators and
so essentially if you've got these
10,000 people wherever there's a
spectator there's a potential camera
operator we got a bunch of people to use
an app and we can kind of collected this
corpus of video and all of our videos
are
have embedded metadata in them and so
that's stuff like GPS to give you kind
of the position on the course where the
video was taken the time it was taken
but then the application that we've made
also allows people while they're filming
too sparse individual runners so it's
got this kind of keypad interface on it
so if somebody runs past the spectator
who's filming keys in the number of the
runner that they've seen and the reason
we did it like this you because you
might imagine kind of you know computer
science we could do some kind of
intelligence identification of runners
but actually it's a really really hard
problem to solve you may be able to do
it with computer vision for example so
have the camera actually read the bib
number on somebody's chest but in a
really densely packed race that's
probably going to be obscured so again
we're using the power of the crowds this
is human computation we're using the
ability of people to recognize people
that they know and easily be able to
read partially obscured numbers and tap
them in in order to again add meaning to
our collection of videos so thinking
about the coverage that we got so the
first time we run this in the 2013 Robin
Hood marathon we had about 20 people
using our app which doesn't doesn't seem
very many but between them they managed
to tag two and a half thousand unique
runner numbers throughout the course so
two and a half thousand people running
in the race were tagged at least once
over the course of the experiment and
between them they make a film about 12
hours of footage and so that's actually
quite a significant amount of
information a very small number of
people have managed to capture and you
might imagine if we could scale that up
so even if just 1% of the spectators at
the de Marathon so so a hundred people
we're doing this you might imagine we
might be able to tag everybody in the
marathon maybe maybe a couple of times
and that that starts to become really
interesting because then we can start
pulling out videos of these people and
telling stories about them or kind of
presenting them maybe active this is
your individual video souvenir of you
running in the marathon and that kind of
sits alongside the kind of the official
finish line race photography that you
get so this is me crossing the line
maybe it'd be nice to say here's me from
a few angles captured by a bunch of kind
of random people along along the route
so in terms of the coverage that we've
got we started looking at the video
corpus to see kind of yeah what did
people do and so one thing you might do
is just say well let's kind of plot all
the video on a map and see what that
looks like but actually that doesn't
really help because if you think about
it there's like six thousand people
running a half marathon for example and
any given point you can kind of stand
and watched a marathon going past for
about half an hour so we have to think
about not just where a video took place
but when over the course of the marathon
it took place so if we draw a graph and
on the left hand side we draw the time
and on the horizontal axis we draw the
distance along the course and so
essentially what we're doing is reducing
our map to a single dimension so saying
that as you run the marathon you you
travel a distance and along that line
there are a bunch of different key
features so in 2013 the route took you
through boots campers and boots or a
large pharmaceutical company based in
Nottingham so the route took you through
this kind of Industrial Estate and then
onto a kind of nottingham university
park and it did like a switchback
through there so kind of up the road and
then kind of back down past the lake so
we spent some time there before going
back into town towards the finish line
around the embankment by the riverside
by translating for so essentially we can
reduce any position on the course to
somewhere on this line both for the
runners but also from the spectators who
is kind of standing by the course
filming it first we can draw the
marathon race on the graph and then we
can kind of over like what footage we
have of that in the top left hand corner
so at 9:30 at the start of the race at
the start line the professional athletes
are going to be in the start
the race waiting for the gun to go off
so we can draw this line the upper bound
of the half marathon race we can draw
this line from 9:30 at the start line to
kind of about 10:30 and they're going to
run the fastest so they're going to be
the first to arrive at the University
Park and they're going to be first to
arrive at the finish line then it's
going to take probably about 20 minutes
half an hour for all of this kind of
6,000 odd runners to pass through the
start line because there's so many of
them but so the last person to cross the
start line is going to cross it maybe
kind of 20-30 minutes later and maybe
they're gonna be a really slow runner
maybe it's gonna take them two two and a
half hours to finish the race so that
allow us to draw this other line the
bottom bound this essentially constructs
a shape as it contains all of the
runners who took part in the marathon so
we can draw lots of trajectories lots of
individual run their stories on our
graph now what we can start to do is
think about where the coverage that
we've collected fits on to this craft so
for example if we had somebody standing
on the University Park standing still
they'll record for a certain period of
time but they won't move so we can draw
a video as a line going down or a block
going down where the path of the runner
intersects this line going down that
we've drawn basically means that
somebody is in the field of view of the
video as we've captured it as we have
lots of people standing around
University Park we can draw lots of
these boxes going down to kind of
represent the coverage that we've got
typically nobody wanted to kind of stand
on Boots campus because kind of it's an
industrial state is not near people's
houses so it's not an obvious place for
people to go and spectate the university
however is its open it was a nice sunny
day it's a nice kind of park area where
people might want to go and spend the
morning so a loss fair spectators went
hung around at the University parks we
have lots and lots of coverage and if we
plot all of the coverage that we've
taken on this graph we can see that
between about kind of eight and a half
miles and ten and a half miles that kind
of period of the race through University
Park we have about 90 percent coverage
of the race as it passes through
technically we have double edge coverage
and so our spectators around the
University Park are essentially you're
acting like a video gateway through
which runners are passing and hopefully
we'll be able to catch a glimpse of them
other bits of coverage we have another
of dense coverage as the race leaves the
University Park we've got quite a lot of
the finish line some of our spectators
hung around the start line and the
finish line because the race starts
finishes in the same place what we can
also do is is now start to add our tags
to this date so if you recall we had a
spectators adding information to this
video footage by keying in runner
numbers what that allows us to do is put
points on a graph where we know that
we've definitely seen one of our runners
so if we've seen runner 1 2 3 within
this video we can mark on that graph and
in another video we can say we've seen
runner 1 2 3 and we can begin to kind of
connect these lines together so we've
got this line that goes from their
official start time through where we've
spotted them to their official finish
time so we can draw this quaint accurate
trajectory of where we've seen these
people and what we can also do is look
where their line intersects a video
where they haven't been explicitly
tagged because it's quite a challenge
for the spectators to tag every single
runner who passes by especially one it's
really crowded but by drawing this line
we can guess that a runner might
actually be in this video because their
line intersects a video that they
haven't been seen in what we can do with
this is is basically pull out a
collection of video fragments some of
which we know the runner is explicitly
in because they've been seen and tagged
and some what we think they might be in
it so we can begin to pull out kind of
these short video stories and actually
what we want to do now is think about
again how we can use crowdsourcing and
human computation and allow open this
collection of video up to allow people
to help us identify people in these
videos that are implicated in
if we know that you're here to watch
your uncle we might say if you go to
this bit of the course you'll be able to
see your uncle because he's going to
turn up in about ten minutes because
he's been tagged ten minutes ago sounds
right now only Apple caller can kind of
make changes to iTunes and therefore we
leave all of the users of iTunes without
help